Look, worry is basically your brain
doing mental push-ups for imaginary
problem. Your brain has this fascinating
habit. It acts like a security guard who
thinks every shadow is a burglar. We're
scanning for LinkedIn notifications
while actual tigers remain noticeably
absent from our daily commute. Here's
the truth. Bomb anxiety is just time
travel with poor Wi-Fi connection.
You're trying to live tomorrow's
problems with yesterday's fears while
missing today's life. Notice how right
now in this exact moment, you're
probably fine. Yet somewhere in your
mind, there's a tiny CEO holding
emergency meetings about stuff that
might happen. When you seal today's
compartment, something incredible
happens. Your problem-solving ability
skyrockets because your full mental
bandwidth focuses on actual challenges.
We spend 90% of our mental energy trying
to control the 10% we can't influence.
Meanwhile, the things we can control get
minimal attention. Your future self
isn't sitting in tomorrow wishing you'd
worried harder. They're reading your
worries like old diary entries and
laughing. When you stop worrying,
everything doesn't just start to go
well. Everything reveals its inherent
wellness. You haven't been fixing life.